okay the final example is the call
center data and rob do you want to tell
us about these data so this is a
simulated data set looking at how long a
person's willing to wait for
an operator to pick up after they've
called
a phone line for asking for help so the
response here is that is the time until
um the call is picked up and it's
possibly censored if the customer
decides to hang up before
the call is answered
and the some of the features are the the
number number of operators that were
available
at the time the call was made
let's see um morning afternoon evening
that time of the day and the center it
looks like right and there's looks like
there's three three call centers a b and
c yeah
and i think we all know about uh call
centers i personally hate call centers
and they put you on hold and you listen
to some horrible music usually scratchy
and noisy
and especially if they have to wait a
long time
all right let's look at the design so so
here's some code
to sample these features so we
we sample
each one of them just randomly right
according to some scheme n is a total
sample size of 2000
and we look at the first few rows
so operators is a numeric number between
5 and 15 the number of operators
and then we have dummy variables for
these each of the the categorical
variable center and time
are three levels
that's one hot encoded not dummy not
dummy one hot encoded
and because
because it's a linear model we
we
we have them each one's relative to a
baseline so one of the levels gets
dropped out
it's a simulation so we need to to
to build a true model so we need
we need to set some coefficients we're
going to make a linear model in these
variables so we set some coefficients
for each of these
variables above here
and
we write a little function to create the
hazard
which this is
x times
.001
so this is just a scaling function let's
see the sum of the coefficients one of
the coefficients
the coefficients for operators was equal
to 0.04
and what that means is that each
additional operator leads to
1.041 fold increase in the risk that the
call will be answered so the time here
is the time to the the call being
answered so obviously the more operators
the higher chance that's going to be
that will be operated
be
answered the coefficient associated with
center b is minus 0.3 and center a is
treated as a baseline this means that
the risk of being of core being answered
at center b
is 0.74 times the risk that it will be
answered at center a
in other words the weight
times are a bit longer at center b
so that gives you an idea of the basis
we use a
package called cox ed
and there's a sim serve data function in
there and it allows us to specify the
maximum possible failure times
in this case which we set to equal to a
thousand seconds for a for a customer
and so we like we we load that package
and you can see it relies on a lot of
other packages
prints them all out
quite a lot
and we call the package
and
we give it the maximum time
we give it our x matrix we give it the
true betas
we give it the hazard function which
scale down the function
and it will generate the data for us
and it gives us a warning
so it tells us that we had
right sensorine which we expected
because we set a maximum to the wait
time
the result is we get the queuing data as
a data frame
and it's got a
bunch of variables
okay
the observed data is stored in in
queuing dollar data
and with y corresponding to the event
time and failed an indicator whether the
call was answered failed is true
or the customer hung up before the call
was answered fail is false
okay
we see that almost 90 percent of calls
were answered you know one of the things
that's tricky about assembling survival
data like if you're doing research and
survival it's hard to know what sort of
what the signal-to-noise ratio is right
like in a linear model you can look at
the
size of the beta and this and sigma
squared and figure out sort of
um how to simulate data of sort of
medium signal-to-noise ratio but
survival data is much more
complicated right so
that you know is is for example are
these betas large are is the sample size
was it a thousand is that large enough
to find effect so it's kind of tricky
right so typically what people what i do
at least is i'll i'll start with some
settings like this and then i'll
produce the data and fit a cox model as
we're going to see right now and look to
see what sort of what kind of p-values
you get and that's sort of a more sort
of sea to the pants way to know
you know just how big the
signal-to-noise ratio is right often you
sort of you pick some settings you fit a
model and then things are very
insignificant and you realize gee i have
to actually make the relative risk
parameters larger for example
and and vice versa
you can you can set the parameters in
the simulation so anything would do well
right right it's just so easy
so it really is
there's a there's an art in in creating
just the right kind of uh simulation
data
90
of of
the people waited
for the call to be answered right 10
percent were censored
they dropped out
so we now plot kaplan-meier survival
curves and we'll first stratify by
center
and here we see them
the
occurs for the three centers not very
different
okay
and now we'll stratify by time
and
time was a time of the day whether it
was morning afternoon or evening
and again not too different
and now we'll do a a
log rank test to see if if center is
significant
and
even though it didn't look significant
in the in the figure the data set's big
enough it turns out it is significant
so this
the center variable
was
this one these were significantly
different
so one thing you can notice is that
the survival curves are very granular
right when in some of the earlier data
sets like the brain cancer data set much
smaller data set big steps so the
granularity is telling you there's lots
of data here and lots of events right
and
90 were events yeah so what our eye
tells us is not a very big difference
it's turned out to be significant in
this case
we probably expect the same thing here
and
sure enough
um
when you do the the
log range test on time it's also
strongly significant
now we fit the
cox proportional
hazards model to the data using all the
variables
and
we see that
center
b was significant compared
different from center a but center c was
not significantly
different from center a
and and both
evening and morning were different
from
midday
right and so that's it
so there we have three examples we fit
the cox model to each
fairly simple
modeling process a very useful tool for
modeling these kinds of data